Linda Gregerson David
[Applause]
thorburn hello are these working now
okay I'm David thorburn I'm the director
of the communications Forum I'd like to
take one quick moment to mention that
this is the first of three forums we're
sponsoring this semester uh the other
two are coming in fairly quick
succession and there are uh there is
information at the back of the room conc
turning them and I won't I won't waste
time talking about them here when I
spoke to Linda is an old friend of MIT
and many of you here have know Linda
from years ago when her husband taught
here and Linda was a somewhat unhappy
and uh ambitious faculty wife uh I think
it I think it was one of blissfully
happy I don't mean she was unhappy with
her marriage I she was UN at all uh but
I got to know her then and I I the from
the very first time I read any of her
poetry I knew that I was in the presence
of a distinctive voice when we talked
about what we would do today uh it
struck me and Linda was kind enough to
agree
that there were I had issues with
traditional poetry readings and one of
the reasons is I think there's something
distinctive about Linda's poetry that
makes it uniquely problematic simply to
hear so one of the things we and there
will be a good deal of reading this is
sort of a reading with commentary and
I'm going to ask Lind engage in a quick
conversation with Linda that will lead
into the reading of some poems and then
when we complete the conversation we'll
open the floor to discussion from or
questions or comments from you and maybe
Linda will read other
poetry when we complete this uh this
what I hope will be a very memorable
event we will have a reception in this
room for all of you who are here and I I
I hope you'll linger for that as well uh
so let's be Linda so Linda and I have
talked about the kinds of things we
would discuss discuss and uh I'm I'm
going to be uh for some of you who are
strong and wonderful poets in the
audience I know there are certainly many
people here who would be more qualified
than I to ask these kinds of questions
but I'm going to try to play uh a really
sort of direct and honest I'm going to
ask naive questions or at least
questions that I think would puzzle not
professional poets but serious but
ordinary readers and try to get Linda to
talk about what I feel at least are at
least some of the most most distinctive
features of her remarkable poetry so the
first topic that um if I can find My
Notes the first topic I thought we would
take up is uh something that is um not
often systematically talked about
especially at poetry readings and it's a
technical question uh uh in her in in in
her early books and especially in the
woman who died in her sleep and water
born Linda used a very
distinctive uh
uh three line stanza which I have come
to think of as the as the Gregerson tet
and and my reason for thinking that and
this is also one of the reasons why in
the back if you don't have these little
readers please pick them up in the back
of the room because we want to test one
of my theories which is that listening
to a poem by Linda no matter how
brilliantly she reads
it it can't be the same as actually
seeing the words on the page and it may
well be that hearing her read and seeing
the the words on the page is the best of
all possible worlds but we're going to
try to test this because at some point
I'm going to ask Linda to will she'll
read a poem that you can't follow and
we'll see if there's a if there's a
difference so I thought we would begin
then by talking about what I suggested
is the um Gregerson tet and Linda let's
begin by why don't you read the first
poem it's poem number one on on on your
sheet uh the resurrection of the body
and we'll talk a little bit as as as she
as try to imagine as she's reading what
it would be like not to not to be able
to see the way the words are disported
on the page I remember once having a
conversation with Lindon in which she
said oh I really like this poet because
his poems breathe on the page and at the
time I didn't fully understand her but
then as I paid more attention to these
poems I realized what she said you can
see how the uh words how this is an
these are exact replicas of the of of
what the pages in her book look like and
you can see how the
have the lines colonize the page in
certain complicated ways and need the
space on the page Linda okay this poem
is called the and can you hear me okay
this poem is called the resurrection of
the
body she must have been 13 or so her
nent breasts just showing above the
velcro strap that held her in her
chair her face
translucent beautiful
as if a cheekbone might directly render
a tranquil heart and yet the eyes were
all dis
quietude the mother with her miraculous
smile frequent durable lifted the
handkerchief you know the way a woman
will her index finger guiding a corner
the body of it gathered in her dextrous
palm and with such tenderness WIP the
spittle pooling at her daughter's
mouth the faint warm smell of lipstick
remember freighted with love and with
that distillate left by fear when fears
been long outdone by fearful
fact the mother would give her soul to
see this child lift her head on her
own and down the hall in orthotic
I couldn't for the longest time
understand why the boy required a helmet
so complexly fitted and
strong his legs were
unused his arms so
thin a treadmill I thought or or a
bicycle maybe some bold new stage of
therapy anyway sometimes he falls and
safe in his helmet can bravely set to
work
again wasn't for nothing that I was so
slow who cannot read these waiting rooms
has so
far exactly so far been
spared it was only while I was driving
home my daughter in her car seat with
her brand new
brace that I thought of the boy's
rhythmic rocking and
new green
light
yellow the tide of pedestrians flush and
smooth and the boys poor head against
the
wall how could I miss it and what does
God in his Heaven do then the boy's poor
head in its bright red helmet knocking
listen to be let
in
I may have slightly undermined the
astonishing power of this poem by having
her read it second instead of first I
forgot my order uh but let's talk I mean
I think the the subject matter of the
poem is so overwhelming that uh it may
seem impertinent to talk about the
technical features of the poem but I'd
like to ask you Linda about about the
way you disport these tetts on the page
and what what what kind
of energy it gives you what kind of in
how it helps you get to your
subject well um I I did have a book I
wrote before these um that um that was
not written in this stanza form and they
were you know they were sort of varied
stanzas but they were basically they
were all flush left and this the lines
were roughly the same length so they
were kind of you know rectangles of one
sort or another and I um I had this
terrible experience there was an
anthology this is ages ago it was one
denh helprin did a sort of all poetry
edition of antas and it was sort of
everybody you know was in it and it was
wonderful to be in it and I was very
pleased and honored and uh we were all
in it alphabetically and I was sort of
reading through from start to finish to
come upon my own poems and when I sort
of turned the page and came upon my
poems I was actually appalled because I
realized that the stza form I was
working in was actually deeply
misleading about the pacing of the poems
and it was that opposite of breathing on
the page they were actually it they
seemed really really airless and that
there was no time between anything and
partly it felt like um it was a betrayal
of the I I I think a lot about syntax I
mean I think if there's one formal
proposition that's common to all of us
now that many of us don't work in
received forms like meter and rhyme that
syntax is it and and it's very important
to me and I felt like there was
no I I I I made a wretched botch of it
by doing by doing the stanzas that way
because it it was not it was misleading
about how to hear the syntax which I
think of as a um which I had I imagined
I'd very carefully just exposed so as to
have a lot of speeding up and slowing
down and sort of pivots and so I I in
despair thought of throwing myself into
the river and then I I thought well
maybe I could mess with the stanza and
so I I just I'm I messed around a lot I
tried a lot of things I didn't do what
might have been more intelligent which
is actually go look at other poets and
see what they'd been doing I just kind
of disposed things on the page and I
finally this one really helped me
because because of its
asymmetries it's three it's also
indented they're not the same length
there's a kind of what I think of as a
pivot line in the middle and it gave me
um a a sort of resistance grid through
which the syntax could move and so I
write um I mean I really write into this
uh I I wrote two books into this stanza
form and and um and and for me it was it
was absolutely essential to sort of
where do I go from here I was being told
where to go from here
by when you when you begin to use the
stanza form it's as if you sort of
embarked on a on a journey you don't
know its outcome when you start yeah
yeah and that was the very reason that
after two books I had to leave it
because I started knowing the outcome
too well I mean not in that not not in
terms of subject for any given poem but
in terms of what it was going to sound
like what the cadences would be what it
kind of you know how where it would
culminate where it
would and and and and so I had to you
know sever myself from what had become a
kind of life support one of the things
that this style depends upon even more
systematically than conventionally left
Justified poetry is the grammer and I
wonder you know in fact you're a deeply
grammatical poet in depend on grammar
even when when you elide or eliminate uh
certain verbal ele certain grammatical
elements in the sentence you're still
aware of what's missing you this is if
you never write
ungrammatically remember consciously
ungrammatically unless it's unless
there's a a dialogue element or
something like that and I I I it's
that's that that uh strikes me as
important interesting too and I I wonder
if you were aware of the fact of the
sort of the rigor of your grammar and of
the extent into which some of the poems
profoundly depend I mean you you can go
on many many lines before you'll get to
the verb and and uh it's only because of
the gr grammatical structure that it's
held in place well I I love grammar it's
my i i i diagram sentences you know I
mean I I I would make everybody do it at
dinner parties if I had my way and um I
uh
I again I I I I think it's I it's I love
the architecture of English
syntax and I think of it as a sort of
social contract it's a it's it's a
contract of expectation it's a promise
if I say I'm if I say I'm you expect
something to come after that and I may
um I may
transgress that contract but the power
of transgression that is being ungr you
know sort of pulling the rug out or or
or or subverting it only has its own
sort of torque if it's um if one has in
mind uh the traditional sort of forward
momentum of syntax and the sort of the
the the the the expectation that has to
do with say a delayed verb and you know
internally branching mod so one point
the fact that there's a momentum
embedded in the grammar is enables
variation because the grammar's momentum
allow absolutely I mean I keep I talk to
my students a lot syntax has gone
missing um in a certain amount of
Contemporary American poetry and I'm
happy to say
not not as
badly as was the case maybe a few years
ago but I I I teach Young Writers a lot
and um I the sort of the vague swimming
in nominatives or or you know which is
which is a very tempting thing to do um
as a poet because you kind of there
feels like immediacy and you're not
being so stiff and straight
jacketed as to um assert stuff which
sentences make you feel as though you're
doing right and it's so it can feel hip
it can feel but you know that but you
sacrifice a huge amount if all you do is
I mean a you can't be just adjectival so
most of these Young Writers are far too
clever to make it that but there is a
lot of floating on nominatives and um
Extended nominatives and and and there
there can be passages of that that is
are actually really wonderful but it
needs to be over something there need
they need to be able to um they need to
have other things in their toolkit Frank
and um and for me a lot of um a lot of
formal variation apart from
um what I've called momentum and this
sort of
disposition um on the page and the uh
disposition on The Voice there's also
the question of just varying length um I
have a a wonderful
um um colleague of of mine not an
immediate colleague colleague but a
friend and colleague who teaches at
Minnesota the um wonderful Pros writer
Patricia Hamilton um Patricia hle when
she is um um teaching workshops she says
I often take a you know if I'm doing she
does creative non-fiction she says I I I
bring tracing paper in and I have my you
know the students take a piece of their
Pros their last essay or their last
short story and they just with a tracing
paper I just have them take a pencil and
Mark
or a pen where all the the end stops are
where the periods are and then they take
their Pros away and they look at the
page and if they're about equal distance
all the time there's a
problem and it's a very it's a really
nice exercise and and I so I mean I'm
just always aware of the sentence I love
the sentence I think the sentence is my
friend um and uh and it it does you know
there are times when I one of the the
the the propositions I'll launch and
it'll be emotional as much as anything
else is I'm going to go I'm G to make
this one last as long as I can I'm just
going to
like go out you know on a on a sort of
I'm going to go over the abyss here and
see how long I can make this go without
coming to a and and and there there's a
kind of um there's a tension there can
be sometimes it can be desperation
sometimes it can be playfulness and
overconfidence but um and and in a way
it it's it it is a vehicle for whatever
um emotional Freight the subject of the
poem may may prompt I well look I we we
probably should let the tets uh live in
their in their in their Glory without
further comment but I I I can't resist a
couple at least one more question about
it because the I find that the the
experience of reading these poems
organized in this way um that two things
happen while while I'm doing that one is
that the strange or unexpected spacing
creates moments of pause where you
wouldn't expect them and that and and
that's then often reinforced by the fact
that when you come to the end of the
line you're not always sure what
grammatical form will follows so that
there's a kind of a kind of mystery or
uncertainty is is introduced almost as
if you can sometimes imagine alternative
choices that you might have made and I I
take it that that's part of your in
absolutely and I I also assume that part
of what you're doing is trying to make
the reader slow
down yeah absolutely so that so that one
of the experiences I've had in in in in
some of Linda's most powerful poems like
the one she just read but many others as
well is the sense I have I wonder if you
intend this Linda that I'm actually
following a mind as it's thinking as it
in other words as as if you as if what's
being dramatized in some sense is the
process of thought and Association
that's going on which a a more simple
lineated poem would not reproduce am I
is that right I'm thrilled to hear you
say that I mean I hope that's very much
my hope um it is authentically the
experience as well I mean I think I
think that's
what that's what form of any sort does I
mean I there are people who would
probably be
appalled and disapproving to hear me
even talk about this is form it's not
traditional form but it is um it is a
set of propositions that that repeat
with
some rough
parameters and uh and and I think for me
I should have said that in the first
place the most important thing about it
is that it actually does make the
unfolding of the poem a discovery
process for me
there is this sort of turning a corner
and not knowing exactly what will will
be there that also replicates in a in a
in an even deeper way an aspect I think
of the experience of reading you Linda
which is that one of your habits I'm
sure that this irritates naive readers
or impatient readers is there's a kind
of obliqueness or or cunning in some of
your poems maybe cunning is not the best
word for what I mean in which certain
information is delayed hinted at and
then it's delayed and you don't get the
answer until later in the poem uh and I
I was Wonder wondering if you could say
a couple of words about that and then
maybe we could look at a poem that
that a poem or two that actually enacts
that process of delayed disclosure I
don't know of a better way to describe
what I mean where you have the reader
has some partial information but there's
some Myster that isn't fully answered
until we get deeper into the poem and
that seems like what you were saying
before for about the reader sort of
replicating in some sense the experience
the poet had making her discoveries well
I think there are I mean I could read an
example of um one that's probably most
explicit okay that that way or um a and
another where I the poem led me into
territory I really didn't think I was
going into but the this pick one these
are not ones that we have on the good so
read one of these and do my test see if
see if it's harder to understand without
being able to see it on the
page okay
um I'll do the
one where there's delayed disclosure and
this was really
um it's
multi-sectioned
um and this was one it's actually part
of my effort be to be as direct as
possible that is I'm really not being
koi I actually hate
kiess obliquity is not coinness okay um
but it's also I think sometimes the most
immediate thing in poetry is not
necessar poet I I believe that narrative
or story or implied narrative is an
enormous part of lyric poetry as well
it's almost always artive that's kept
off the page so there'll just be a touch
that will so it's it's it's they'll
it'll be it'll be suggested as existing
in the white space in the surround or
prior to the poem um but I I actually
think the thrust of implied narrative is
a huge part of lyric that we often
forget to acknowledge but um but story
telling in poems is very rarely a matter
of this happened then that happened then
that happened there's the sort of um um
what's most urgent and
then in what sequence do you unpack it
to make sense of it and and and and
that's that's can
be
both um an emotional trajectory I think
ideally it's both emotional and a kind
of cognitive or analytic even um that
it's the two happening together okay so
this poem is called safe and uh and it's
written in the tets WR in the tets it
may have been the first one I actually
wrote in this form um and it's in four
sections one you should give the title
safe
one the tendons sewn together and the
small bones healed that your hand might
close on a pencil again or hold a
cup the delicate muscles made whole
again to lift your eyelid and govern
your smile and the nerves new laid in
their
tracks the broken point of the kitchen
knife and here let the surgeon be gentle
removed and the skull knit closed and
the blood lifted out of the carpet and
washed from the
stairs and the 19-year-old burglar
returned to the Cradle or his mother's
arms he must have been harmless once
even he who is not
sorry had nothing to
lose and will never be harmless
again
two Emma is learning to wield her own
spoon silver for
abundance though it seldom finds her
mouth as yet she hates to be fed would
rather starve but loves to steer the
precarious course herself
silver for Pride then or luck of the
sort some children are born with
omitting the manifold slippage that
separates privilege and
wheel luck in his popular figure is
three parts silver anyway that the child
not succumb to crack in the schoolyard
rats in the hall the clever fence with a
shopping list bad Plumbing bad food and
hatred on a staircase with a knife in
hand and dim designs on jewelry or a
VCR the spoon was
superfluity the best part of your
paycheck for a child you haven't lived
to
see
friend her cheek is fresh as hope of
paradise and every passing minute in the
hours of light and the hours of darkness
in the fever of pneumonia or the
ignorant sweet wash of Health the
miraculous breath moves into her lungs
and Stitch by mortal Stitch moves
out
three when the paramedics came at last
my friend
apologized she must have hit her head
she thought she'd just take a minute to
mop up The Mess by the
phone her broken hands for which the
flaw in memory had provided no such
alabi her broken hands had kept him two
or three times from her
face and later when the anesthesiologist
had launched her on his good green gas
and launched her as they do sometimes as
shade too fast she slipped the bonds of
recall all all
together safe as
houses you know what a house is for the
likes of us down payment on the nursing
home our four square pledge to be
debtors of conscience if debtors in
conscience may not look too closely
where credits
refused our piece of the here for
Hereafter which shows us diminished
regard and just such a face
as fear has
made one night a woman came home to her
house and locked its useless locks and
buttoned her night dress and read for a
while and slept till she was
wakened so um that is the story of it's
an elegy for a friend of mine who
um was killed by an
intruder and um I even lied a little bit
in it I made him a burglar um he wasn't
he'd actually stalked her and just come
in to um murder her I also suppressed
the fact that he was a young man of
color um
because
um because I needed to keep a different
openness in the poem I thought um
I it felt um
very um it felt like very difficult to
Rin to begin with and
um I had no
business I had no
business claiming certain kinds of
suffering myself or or making judgments
um I certainly didn't want to mouth pies
about
race in America or um relative um
economic deprivation and hardship but um
I had to make um I guess I had to guard
against the wrong kinds
of
uh pity and the wrong kinds of
complaint um and I also had a story
wanted to tell and
I
I I think I needed to begin with what
was most sent was the was the near Miss
of um my friend almost
being safe almost being alive but not um
of having been
lost as so many are kind
of inadvertently on an operating table
afterwards I also had a very young my
first young child at the time and and
the link was um a gift that this friend
had sent when my daughter was
born um and also the kind
of struggle um that all of us were going
through in trying to manage first homes
and early jobs and
paying mortgages and um and and and and
and early stability you know something
that you said about I mean I it this is
a
like most of your poems take on what
turn out to be immensely difficult and
often painful subjects in in in
something of the same sort of tone
of respect unsentimental respect that I
I I it's one of the aspects of your poem
poems that I most admire but one of the
things you said I thought was especially
interesting Linda and it was that you
changed the facts here and because so
many of your poems seem grounded in
autobiographical truth I mean and some
of and we'll read some of those poems
that talk about your ancestors and so in
a in a bit uh one of the things I'm
wondering is did you change those facts
was did did the things you told us about
Grandpa oie were they
I mean that would be very disappointing
to me no I and I all I did all I did was
in and and to be all I did was insert
the line about dim designs on jewelry
and a vcr and I kept true I mean I made
them dim and I also made it part of um
uh uh a
metaphorical
um
um vehicle as it were I didn't say
that I was describing exactly that so
that was very reassuring that's the
broadest Liberty I took that's the broad
I'm glad see one reason that I those of
you who know Linda's poems I think will
understand why this makes me uneasy
because one of the as you'll see from
poems that she'll be reading shortly one
of the most powerful claims you make uh
or the one of the one of aspect of the
poems that uh especially the ones that
contain sort of stories of your father
or your grandfather or your uh your your
um um ANC your your your Norwegian
ancestry in the Upper Midwest uh one of
the things that makes them so powerful
is that they seem to come out of a kind
of personal witness and it seems to me
that the reader hears in those poems a
claim of truthfulness and that and that
you would that that it's an example in a
in a certain sense of what what one
might mean when one's what it means to
use the first person or to write out of
personal experience and it would seem to
me that you'd be violating some contract
if you were inventing these ancestors
age I agree I think I think the poems
invite um the reader to believe
um that they're truth-based um poems
like these certainly do um when I might
be writing you know Dao poems that might
be a little different um very different
um but that there are specific gestures
to indicate not only somehow this really
happened reader but um
this I have um this mattered to me for
some reason that's there's some
proximity so so in the resurrection of
the body
um I didn't just invent scenes
in pediatric neurology
clinics um that business about my
daughter with a brand new brace in her
car seat was meant to be the the how did
I find myself there and and why in a way
am I
so heart
sickened um and why am
I confessing my relative immense good
luck I mean why you know so it's so it's
so when I invite the reader to think I'm
showing you my stakes in this I actually
think it's
extremely I mean it's extremely
important to me that it be true that
that be actual um that's not um that's
not a universal understanding of um
maybe maybe lyric speaker maybe I could
ask you Linda not to to read actually
this was the poem I wanted to begin with
but it works in here too uh another poem
that's very similar in some ways to what
you've seen but it all it shows how when
uh I mean this is a this is a mode I
think in which Linda works especially
powerfully I mean the her her poems are
those of you who've read her know this
are are full of uh a lement for the for
the Frailty of the Body for the for the
for the accident of
of bad biological luck uh and many of
her poems are are are are are
astonishing sort of Lyric laments over
this uh well here's a poem also written
in the Tet style it's number four on
your on your sheet and it also will
allow us to say a little bit more about
grammar and my favorite grammatical mood
which is the subjunctive um I one of the
great Revelations I had about this is
tribute to a local okay a Cambridge
local to what it is that you know
practical criticism could do for the
world was when I read um the preface um
to Helen vendler's beautiful first book
on Wallace Stevens and where she
explains what he does with the
subjunctive how he makes a world how he
builds Castles in the Air how he'll
start his propositions he'll start poems
in the subjunctive mood and simply
modulate without our quite you know
knowing where into the indicative
because he's that which he has proposed
as if has assumed that much critical
mass inside the poem anyway um I was not
by any means trying to be either Helen
vendler or or or Wallace Stevens here
but I do love this subjunctive and I
think it's a it's a it's a you know it's
a place that as if or contrary to fact
um uh or hypothetical that is really
important to human imagination generally
and certainly to poetry and and this
should this should be a good test
because there are there are profound
similarities between the poem Linda just
read which was not on the one that was
not on our sheets and this one and my
implicit belief is
that magnificently as she reads i' have
only heard her read once before and I'm
again you her her reading is wonderful
nonetheless if I can't see Gregerson on
the page I don't feel I'm getting her
and see if you agree with
me um grammatical
mood
one there is to her mind only one or
only one that's built to scale had they
known
sooner had the only man to whom the CAT
scan yielded so much detailed
information not been out of town that
week had those few sticky platelets
moved with just a shade more Expedition
through the infant
artery the parallel life will not
relent
but look we may say to her look at them
tied to their breathing
machines they do not
cry because of the tubes you'll say
you're right to you the silence is
Dreadful to you the vicious calculus
abides no
counterargument the oxygen that
supplements their unripe lungs destroys
the retina leaving the twice struck
child in
darkness what must they think of us
bringing them into a world like
this
two for want of an ion the synapse was
lost for want of a synapse the circuit
was
lost for want of a circuit the kingdom
the child the social
smile and this is just just one of the
infinite means by which the world may
turn
aside when my young daughter whose right
hand and foot do not obey her made us
take off the training wheels and rode
and fell and pedal and fell through a
week and a half of Summer Twilights and
finally on her own traversed the block
of breathing Maples and the shadowed
Street I knew what it was like to
fly sentiment softens the bone in its
socket half the gorgeous light show we
attribute to the Setting Sun is
atmospheric
trash Joy is something else again Ask
Megan on her two bright
Wheels
three to live in the
body as if there were another
place to graze among the
aelas which are poison to humans beloved
by dear not everything the eye enjoys
will sit benignly on the
tongue it must have been a head shot
left her ear at that frightening angle
and the jaw all wrong so swollen it's a
wonder she can
chew is that where they aim the good
ones when they're
sober at the
head at a
d the DNR biologist is saintly on the
phone though God knows he's not chiefly
paid to Sav the conscience I have bad
dreams of a gardening species stricken
by its own
encroachment facundity starve the deer
in the forest it fouls the Earth it
feeds it upon funded plants the Suburban
aelia which dies to keep that keep the
damaged deer in pain I mean
alive
four for want of rain the corn was
lost for want of a bank loan we plowed
up the Windbreak and burnt it you must
learn to think on a different scale they
told us
that for want of a wind break and
rainfall and corn the top soil rose on
the wind and
left God's Own strict grammar imperative
mood I meant to return to Joy
again just give me a minute just look at
the
sky I think that would make a great
title for a for a book of uh criticism
of readings of of Linda's work just give
me a minute just look at the sky U
there's a kind of plangency in it that I
especially because of her earlier
description of the fact that most of
what we see in the sky is junk and ugly
it's it seems to me a a line of Genius
um a couple of things about this poem
Linda that I'd like to ask you about and
one of them is the way in which you
disrupt
the somewhat regular expectations you
have from the your own tets why do you
do that in words for example in section
section four begins with the final line
of a tet is if you said break it up and
this is something of course that you do
elsewhere I mean why do you do that why
is it important to do
that um I guess so it doesn't get too
boring um partly of course it's a kind
of cheating um it's I I mean I did that
each of of these sections breaks you
know in the midst of a tet rather than
at the end of one and I guess it's it's
a way of resisting too much tidiness I
suppose you know the negative way of
looking at it it's like doing an off-
Ryme when you haven't been able to find
it you full rhyme I mean it's it's a I I
didn't want to milk um a stanza to uh to
to so as to for the sake of making a
section end with a full tet um
that seemed to me wrong even though the
sections are in some sense logically
distinct from each other in in some ways
yeah well I kept I think it's also a
transition device isn't it it is I mean
there's a there's there it it's meant to
be a a meditation on a single um subject
actually but but from different angles
right right uh yeah yeah by the way when
wi and I were living in Palo Alto there
would be kids do you remember dogs and
kids would periodically get poisoned
eating the aelas in the road to dendrin
you know they'd have they'd be taken off
to Stanford hospital and we'd hear about
them was but the dear love my aelas it's
all quite
sad embedded in our conversation so so
far um or or embedded in the poems that
we've read uh are certain themes that
it's obvious are even from the small
Ling you've seen recur in Linda's poetry
regularly but one place in which they
recur uh I'm thinking now about the sort
of what what could we call it the sort
of the lament about the the
physiological lament the the the lament
about the about the realities of of our
of our physical life and the and the
accidents we suffer shows up in so many
different contexts in her work but one
of the most powerful ways in which they
show up as as seen in this poem uh in
the reference to your own to your own
daughter uh is the way in which these
this concern about about the body's
Frailty converges with the with what
I'll call the biographical or the
autobiographical and i i w i was um I
think we haven't yet sort of looked at a
poem in which what I call your ancestral
Saga appears and I thought we might do
one of those um how about constitutional
which which uh uh has another virtue for
us
something that we haven't been this is a
very partial view of of the range of
Linda's poetry and I apologize for that
but what I have my own limitations and
there's certain aspects of our work that
have addressed me so deeply that I um
have focused on them uh and what what
happened constitutional will seem
familiar even if you've never only seen
the poems that we've just looked at
today but you'll also think I I think
see an an enlargement what uh in two
directions one is what I've called the
the Gregerson ANC ancestral Saga uh and
there are a number of poems that do this
it's constitutional with particular
energy and disturbing Force but um what
we also see Happening Here is a
turn toward what I'm the more overtly
political and some of Linda's poems are
very directly uh uh political poems and
I think you can see uh in this poem
something of the way those two come
together and I was hoping after you read
that you I talk a bit about that okay I
should say first that I feel very queasy
about you know doing this sort of family
poem um
I just I'll just say that I
um I the kind of you know ethnic
recidivist sort of like you know I'm so
moved by the spectacle of my own roots
and I mean I I I feel very anxious and
wey about it I try not to you're not so
celebratory Linda I mean the portrait of
your father that emerges in books no I
don't no okay right I mean you're pretty
tough on these people it's not you're
not it's not I love them it's not sacker
in Praise it's it's pretty
tough-minded this is called
constitutional and I should say it
wasn't quite written on assignment but
David Barber said you know we're trying
to put together some poems for whatever
the summer issue of the Atlantic was at
one point he said he just would like
America as their theme he said do you
have anything I said I I don't know but
there was this thing I was thinking
about writing so anyway constitutional
so constitutional and and it's an allogy
um it's a wonder they didn't all of them
die of the sun those days remember
olie's forehead in the backs of his
hands the fair-haired sons of Norway in
their bright Wisconsin Fields the map of
blessed Second Chances writ in tassled
corn the damage r it in
melanin I never could stand it my father
would say by which he meant the morning
constitutional the dose of electric
fencing all he found was just the cure
for Frozen
joints but joints be damned the rest of
it my father loved he'd cast about for a
portion I could manage maybe Linda could
fetch the
cows poor man he little thought how
quickly the race declines
ourselves and our
posterity it all alarmed me dung slicks
Culvert swollen
teeth the single narrow wire above the
barbed ones commotion of flies on the
rim of the
pale we're better at living on paper
some of us better at blessings already
secured the
fence it was for
animals and and insulated quaintly with
a species of porcelain
knob that part at least I had the wit to
find
benign like the basket of straw flecked
eggs a touch of homely caution in the
liable deter inous
World ordain and
establish and breakable
too and old man at his battery charged
devotions double fisted on the six Vault
fence in order to
form a measure of guesswork a measure of
faithful refraining from harm let us
honor the virtues of
form and all the dead in company if only
not to shame
them
um this was in the earlier phase of of
our extraordinary Renditions and other
bad behavior on a global scale um and so
it seemed like something that actually
is meant to be a kind of homage um one
thing I wanted to ask also had to
include that right I mean I this is one
of my favorite poems of of of Linda but
for many reasons but one of them is that
it uh like other poem of yours that I
very much admire um the sense of a
conversation going on between you and
the reader is particularly powerful and
there's a moment in the poem when you
where you're making your confessions
about what a bad farmer you are and you
say you know it I hated the dung slicks
and the Culvert and so forth and then
you then uh when you finish that little
discourse and you say we're better at
living on paper some of us better at
blessings already secured then you say
the fence question mark and and clearly
you're talking to the reader there
you're saying oh reader I didn't quite
tell you about the defense yet yeah now
this happens in other of your poems
but the kind of the kind of connection
that's implied or or required of the
reader in order to participate in the
poem seems to me a peculiarly intimate
one as if as and uh um I'm wondering
if this is something that's in your mind
when you start to write the poem or does
do you do you do you begin to feel
that you're in a in some of the poems
that you're in a much closer dialogue
with your auditor than than in others
well honestly David I think some of it
has to do with wanting to make sure the
poem doesn't rattle on on a single pitch
of
diction um or a single kind of in a
single rhetorical posture the whole time
that it does that that it moves I mean
it's a wonder they didn't all it's meant
to be be deeply informal the way it
starts but also to somehow accommodate
that um and it's got but joints be
damned but but it's got sort of higher
um he little thought how quickly the
race you know it's got other pitches of
of diction and those bits from the um
Preamble to the
Constitution and um and and so I think
that the conversational and the just
being able to have a
little to word um phrase that's a
question you know I I think it's much
it's about it's about
breaking um momentum rhetorically it
really is so it's moving it's be moving
in and out of the
acknowledged um intimacy this is it's
interestings important this is connected
to rather than just presuming on it all
the time right I mean it seemed I hadn't
realized how this is connected to what
you said before about how you became
bored with left Justified poetry as if
there was something simp to as if you're
you're in a very good build we were
walking through a very good building for
this we took a tour of sta Linda had
never seen the Gary building before so
we took a tour of it and in some ways it
seems to me there was a connection
there's your poems are much more
beautiful and elegant than than that
ugly thing but uh I get paid much better
as well yeah but but uh I guess I guess
what I have in mind is just this this I
hadn't realized how important it was to
you to
keep people on edge in a sense to or or
at least or at least to change registers
repeatedly enough so that you don't fall
into any pattern well I don't want them
for example I I'm I'm desperately afraid
of the
hortatory but I also I think I kind of I
do think it's possible to get you know
for intimacy to be too um to to Really
to be presumed upon I think having
Touchstone moments where it's it's it's
it's it's convers where the registers of
the conver where the gestures of the
conversational um enter the poem that
feels really important to me I I guess
it is a kind of Mobility I don't mean it
it's not meant to be like
ambushes um but rather a sort of changes
of tonal tonal variation I mean there's
some astonishing moments in some of
Linda's poems where she
will suddenly address you she'll say
reader not I married him but
almost as good as that
line um where that same kind of intimacy
comes in I always experience it as
a both as a surprise but also also as
something that draws me to the poem in a
way that is very very unusual not not
because it never happens in other poetry
but it seems to me to rarely happen in
the middle of poems it it really happens
that you're surprised by it in the way
that we sometimes are in your poetry as
if they're we know we're in a kind of
intimate connection to you because
you're
sharing complex and disturbing and and
and and private and intimate thoughts
and we can even feel the process of your
of your of your thinking as we follow
along and yet there also still are these
surprising moments in which you seem to
pull back and either include us in a way
that actually says reader pay attent
reader I'm addressing you as as you were
implicitly doing with the fence uh and
then others where you back off that and
I I I hadn't realized uh as clearly
before how how what you're partly after
are these tonal variations and part of
it's a sort of punctuation as well I
mean I also um you don't have to know
this but I another thing I do sometimes
um much to
the well what to the dis trying the
patience of my longsuffering um husband
is I stick him in as a skeptical
interlocutor so I have him like say
something that that punctures um and I
know I'm really representing what he
really thinks like a great deal of
impatience with Nordic Gloom um um but I
do make it a little more slapstick than
he is um would necessarily be in public
and um but but that's also to sort of
and it's partly wanting that it's partly
a form of
inoculation right I don't want to um um
I I I want to punk less I seem to be
taking certain stances um too seriously
I mean I understand what you're saying
and I I I I I'm sure that of course this
is true but I think that you're you're
undervaluing those moments where Stephen
or other moments like that uh interrupt
the flow maybe we could give them an
example how about the title poem of the
new book uh what it's we actually have
it here so you can actually follow it
along um I think you can hear
I think you can hear this one but if you
want to look at it you can but the point
is that this poem contains one of those
moments where where Stephen interrupts
her and says come on it's basically
about my driving which is a family joke
but it does something else as you listen
to it I think you'll find this
interesting um because it does something
else in I mean it grounds the poem in
the moment of its composition it makes
you aware of the circumstances of the
writing in a way that creates a new form
of self-reflexiveness in the text that I
think is even more important in a way uh
than than the things you've been saying
about it but it's a very resonance
strategy that like all of her things
Linda uses sparingly because obviously
not something to overuse but is always
seems to me to happen with great effect
so here's an instance this is actually
the titled poem in in in my new book and
it as you'll hear immediately It Was
Written in the wake of the last
presidential election the cell see the
political coming in too and for those of
you who are not seamstresses Salvage
refers to that when you buy fabric by
the bolt it refers to that part of the
the weaving that um that alters on the
edge to keep this fabric from unraveling
that's what Salvage is um one so door
too among the shotgun Shacks in CAE and
Wayville in our cleanest shirts and
ma'am and excuse me we're all but second
nature now and this one woman comes to
the door she must have weighed
£300 would you be willing to tell us who
you plan to vote for we say and she
turns around with Everett who we voting
for the black guy says Everett the black
guy she says except that wasn't the
language they used they used the word
we've all agreed to banish from even our
innermost thoughts which is when I knew
he was going to
win two
too at which point the speaker discovers
as if the lesson were new she has told
the story at her own
expense amazing said my sister's
Chairman's second wife to think what
you've amounted to considering where
you're from which she imagined was a
compliment one country
friends where when we have to go there
as depend upon it fat or thin regenerate
or blinker to the end we shall they have
to take us in I
saw
three a river full of geese as I drove
home across our one lane
bridge 400 of them easily close massed
against the current and the bitter wind
some settled on the ice and just the few
at a time who'd loosen rank to gather
again
Downstream as if to
paraphrase the fabric every minute Bound
by just that pulling out that holds the
raveling
together you were driving all this time
said Steven counting
geese the snow falling into the river
no the river about to give itself over
to I I'd
stopped their
wingspans had they not been taking
shelter here as wide as we are
tall well I think I should stop asking
questions and let uh uh either members
of the audience ask questions and also
get Linda to read a few more poems we'll
continue until uh 6:30 either with
questions or reading any comments
questions should we get things going by
asking Linda to read a few more why
don't you why don't you give us some you
want me to choose or you choose
uh you choose one and I'll choose one
okay uh why don't we why don't we choose
one that's still on our list so people
can also follow if they
like how about the woman who died in her
sleep okay this is
um yes it's number two number two
yeah oh well more medical dramas again
um Linda's cancer diagnosis happens you
know in section three um
okay um and and and it's a it's it
begins as an eastic poem um there's a
fabulous photographer whose name is
Jeffrey Silverthorne who did a sequence
um he called morg work um and he he he
did at the time anyway live in Indiana I
don't know if he's still there he's a
Midwestern photographer um and they were
extraordinary photographs um of post
autopsy uh bodies in in in the county of
Mor the woman who died in her sleep
which is the title of one of his
photographs
one not whip Stitch nor blind stitch nor
any sort of basting stitch I re
recognize black cordage really piercing
its way from cubis to breastbone why not
up to
shoulder the coroner's question flatly
left to the body's implacable
gray the part in her hair is Jagged
too amazing what the flesh can make of
all this
Interruption you've gathered that she's
beautiful
two when Megan chose the 15th century
sculpture
rooms I realized with some shrin she
hadn't any notion who these people
were the one in blue I said is Mary and
the one she's holding in her lap till
Megan got the gist of it and here I said
is how you'll know him when they take
him down Five Wounds
but my 5-year-old daughter saw
six have I told you do you know for
yourself how the sweetness of creation
may be summed up in the lightfall on a
young girl's
cheek the wound she hadn't yet learned
to ignore the Mortal one was where the
child had once been joined to something
else
three
she'd had worse news the pale
one she'd felt Terror sink its claw and
hold and never had she lapsed into so
lumpish a
cliche the bright young surgeon showed
her how to read the dark
transparency The Telltale script of
cells gone
wrong and like some dull beginner she
began to lose the edge of things and had
to sit I'm sorry had to drink some water
I'm not like this I can
hear the punishment for self-absorbed
she thought is
self-absorbed and all this black
periphery is chiefly lack of blood flow
to the brain poor brain it's body
too is this this old embarrassment the
way I'll
know
four the woman in the photograph is
lying on a pallet made of wood and
though her abdomen appears to have been
packed again in haste and though the
breast is badly sewn her hips are smooth
parentheses her cheekbones High her
lovely arms disposed as though in ler a
luxurious
thought they took my mother's teeth
away they had to I can understand the
morphine I'd bullied them into providing
was meager and frequently
late and so my mother's face was not the
face I
knew but reader her fine forehead was a
blessing on the
place the
lesson though I'm clumsy here has
something to
do
five with
beauty and
use the Sculptor whose grammar my Megan
recites a hole in each hand a hole in
each foot an entry point beneath the
breast believed we get our bodies
back and all the Urgent calculus that
death can found and dissolution expedite
was lavished in that era on this one
account what of the
fingernails what of the hair the Menses
the milk
the proud flesh worn For Heaven's
Sake who'd want you see the body
oblivious body on which the stern salt
tide had left no
Mark when Megan hadn't yet been born two
months to go my ankles swelled and
doubled over every pair of shoes I
wore
unseemliness you seem to have something
in mind
imagine said the people once a world
where nothing is thrown
away this is actually the other
resurrection of the body poem it's
secretly stashed in
there it's kind of a nice beginning and
end Linda why don't you choose one that
takes us that takes us out of the uh out
out of the Cancer Ward out of the Cancer
Ward oh I could do something I could do
I let's see let's see I'm going to do
something here
um well you know we the one thing you
haven't discussed that I mentioned that
I would be happy if you sort of address
this maybe you could do it in connection
to a poem one poem that would work this
way is no lion no moon which is on here
but there may be
others the converence of the political
I'm a short poem first then no lion no
no moon I'm going to do the I don't read
I don't write short poems very often but
I try and it also has the virtue of
being a love poem to my husband um you
have to remember the part about when we
were kids and you we walked down
sidewalks and you there was this like if
you step on a crack you break your
mother's back if you step on a line it
always freaked me out um that stuff
anyway this is called slight
Tremor the fine fourth
finger of his fine right
hand just
slightly when he's tracking our path on
his iPhone or repairing the clasp on my
watch I will not think about the my and
sheath slight Tremor only
transient so the flaw in the pavement
must have been my mother's
back um and is no lion New Moon here yes
it's in here it's uh yeah here we are
okay so this number five begins in the
the um some of you will have been there
in um the Jewish Museum in the city of
Prague and it's got one of the rooms um
assembles and
displays um a a series of the children's
drawings that were done by the Jewish
children who had been bred up um and uh
taken to um terine or teresian Shad uh
the Concentration Camp
outside that um
um uh that city um I was struck in
particular by this one because I spent
my life I think at least once a day
about the play within a play in um
Midsummer Night's Dream because I think
it is the greatest moment in world
literature so um I was very struck they
must have been doing plays in the
concentration camp as well because um
young stepan Pollock his drawing was of
a scene from that play within a play and
this is called no no
moon but there she is fairby
twice the once in durndle and
embroidered
blouse then letter by letter tisby on
the wall
above heart with arrow glossing the name
the heroins
Affliction and by consequence her claim
on
us cheap paper much yellowed these 60
years
the crayon wielded not so much with art
as with the art of
open-heartedness which makes me think
her lover himself so easily undone by
words and by an open heart unlikely to
have scorned the hand that formed the
letters Mis
proclaiming pram just above his
head what's pyramis to you
child or you and all
Terian to
fby that someone had the wherewithal to
find the children crayons at all or
guide them through
theatricals that
someone not just someone but the some of
them the common wheel inside this
unfamiliar and malignant place this
Camp could find the heart to care for
pictures plays within a play and
injudicious lovers long before their
Keepers thought to use such things as
camouflage the Red Cross sent observers
once and caring for such things to make
of them something like a nursery for the
yet to be exterminated solely of Central
Europe is a not not even malice on the
grand scale has
dissolved thisby knows so little of the
world as
yet the bit she can see through the
in the wall has made her heart
beat faster in its
cage but little as she knows she knows
the one thing there are forms for this
his eyes will be like lips like she is
not
required no more than the guards who
have loaded the trains to make the whole
thing up from
scratch the
transcript and that stubborn other thing
that gets transcription slightly wrong
if only rarely in our
favor youngan left the lion
out
I can see this is one of those long
sentences that's way way I thinking of
this when we talked about your use of
grammar in order to get this poem you
have to go back to the that there's that
one very long sentence a long sentence
uh where does it begin Linda begin that
someone had the where someone had
thewith so a lot how long you make us
wait before well you know it's also
that it's partly I think stalling on
letting those children be
killed um and partly it's trying to what
is it you know that someone had the
wherewith ultimate I mean there's
something that it's it's a hard moral
challenge to know what to say about the
face of that
um courage that faith in
culture in the face it didn't keep those
children alive
um but kept something alive for a Time
time so the part of it is actually that
you know the it's it's it's suspended
it's kind of canal levered that I think
of that you know when when there's this
long um dependent set I in this instance
it's a noun
clause um it it it's it's it's it it is
over an abyss it's about to tip the
sentence is always about to like you
know not make it um and and I guess for
me it a good faith measure is that it
actually also always has to be about
something that is the Dilemma in
thinking through in here so so the
delays and the retardations are part of
the emotional texture yeah almost
required what is it to be said about
that kind of
um that going on that that you know
leading the children in drawing classes
um at death's doorstep it it's
incredibly moving um as a spectacle of
what
community is for and can do and must do
and
also profoundly about the limits
of what it can do and what it can't
prevent um so part of it is trying to
you
know was getting more and more um in
trouble
about
knowing what to say and yeah one thing
to claim on its behalf that was
magnificent Lind one of the things that
that uh struck me was the way in which
Linda's explanation changed the poem as
part of the experience of reading this
poem is not knowing about terasen do not
knowing exactly what she's describing
until it discloses itself later in the
poem but she gave that away when she
explained it because and I think the
reason is listening is much harder than
looking on the page you can't go back
you can't uh but if you if you imagine
reading this poem without Linda's
explanation about where who this child
is I mean there's a hint of course
because you see his name and his dates
but and he was 12 when he died you so
but you know it's it takes a while
before that meaning un fully unfolds for
the reader and I think that is part of
the terrible power of this remarkable
poem
give us another one
um okay you know one thing we've not
touched on Linda or what I'll call sort
of your professorial poems your learning
poems maybe you want to do da one of
your D one about book I'll I'll and you
can explain maybe why da is why Dao yeah
well why I think I think because Dao has
haunted Western imagination um and uh
for real reason um but but the the the
Practical re reason is that I I I was
kind of commissioned by a um composer
and dramatic soprano wonderful composer
Susan bti um who herself had been
commissioned to write a series of songs
and we talked and talked about what that
might be and
um where we might go for subject matter
and um and finally uh selected um the
story of Dao and and so I wrote a series
of of of lyrics in her voice but Dao is
um daido is Empire's guilty conscience I
mean she was a great imperialist herself
too after fleeing from TI she sort of
with
great resilience and no little amount of
cunning um built a city on uh in North
Africa but then of course was undone by
um anas
who with whom she fell in love who left
her because he had to go on to better
things and um bigger things and and uh
so she she's represents but and she
comes she really comes back a lot in um
well in in our period in in the early
modern especially um but she's she's
she's a she's a recurrent figure um
and and I think she's she's the she's
the discard she's what it cost to get
where we are um I I I think that's
that's one of the functions she has and
one of the reasons she's she's
fascinating so
um not the only Dao poem you've written
either you no it's not the only Dao poem
I've written um but maybe
um um uh
do two or three of these and then I'll
stop
um so here's section
one
um the four dayss oh it's called da
refuses to speak because it takes us its
present moment that moment when anas
comes upon her in the Underworld and
says oh my God so you are dead the
rumors I heard were true I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to make you Despair and da
like who'd been begging him to day last
time he saw her alive just
turns and doesn't speak so here she's
speaking but it's called da refuses
she's not speaking to him one the four
stays the stern sheet the benches the
yard the wooden pins to which the ores
are bound with strips of leather he
explained this th and
Loom I thought the words were just as
lovely as the workings
and I thought I knew the
principle the moving forward facing
where you've been the muscled quarrel
with the muscled
sea like love that sweet
against and the linen
sail happy the Weaver whose work might
bed deck the chamber where we lay us
down how strange it seems from just a
little
distance the living tree the axe the
Chisel cattle whom we kill and
skin also that they may live again on
water but including
us
two because she'd never not been
there my
Anna I can feel her now the back of her
hand as I hold it against my
eyelid I've always loved to touch with
eyes because her voice was all the
traction I'd ever
required because so long as Earth
contained precisely that measure of
Temple to eyebrow eyebrow to lip I knew
I had a
home it was my sister I made to make the
ready the firewood in its lofty
escarpment the Torches the
oil and she of course when she asked
what I meant to do to whom I
lied I
meant my bitter heart to foul the wind
that filled his
sails I did not ask what if the wind
should change direction who would
choke and one
more
once in a narrow
Garden I encountered a thing I'd known
before a
scent I had no words for
it not Citron though it bore that
solvent aptitude
not
Anis though it harbored a touch of
clay a fragrance I had known as in
another life or this life but before the
daily watering
down which left me half
transported on an undistinguished plot
of ground so think what it meant when he
began to speak
speak the story We stowed as ballast on
the fleeing ships had painted on our
Temple walls the very lights and darks
we had depended on to make the place
less strange and on a stranger's
lips to
whom the story properly
belonged or he to it is there a
difference
and poor Dao mere excursus for them
both thank you thank you
Linda